first off with the session so this is
Katerina she's my teaches results in
provinces yet thank you thank you for
the invitation so I am going to talk
about people become clearness and
connections with cryptography and
lattices and this talk is based on works
with Michael go sweeties come a Sandman
Elizabeth a kiss on your ladies so let's
start for with a brief introduction on
complexity so this is the most classical
picture of complexity where we have n P
and P and a special class in NP that we
call and complete which are the hardest
problem is finding P so in this talk of
focus instead of the decision problems
to the search the search version of
these problems and the picture is still
the same we have the problems that are
solved upon a polynomial time and F and
P is the class of problems whose
decision version isn't complete so
instead of M apart from the problems
that we know that either lie in P or are
np-complete there are many other
problems such as graph isomorphism
finding mascal etcetera but we don't
know whether they are polynomial time or
whether they are anti completely and
there are a lot of cryptographic
assumption and lattice problems that
also lie in this space in between in
order to to classify this problem a new
complexity landscape has been introduced
and this complex landscape the main the
main class in this landscape is what we
call TF NP which stands for which
contains all total search problems so
totally totality means that the problem
a problem that it's total always has a
solution so an F and P is the class of
problems whose decision is an NP and TF
and P is the class of search problems
that always have a solution and since
the introduction of this
complex this class we have some results
that so that this is probably different
than NP so if our problem is in t NP
then and then under determinist it
cannot be open to complete under
deterministic reduction unless and P is
equal to NP and for randomized reduction
we have a wicked result that says that
if this is the case then satis checkable
and it's a very interesting problem to
see whether we can get a result like
that with a randomized reduction sense
of techniques voltage yeah it's a it's a
way deception yeah it's not it's not a
standard as this one so let's see how
what was the idea behind the pilot so
Papadimitriou when he defined the tiffin
p problems he he tried to classify these
problems based on on the mathematical
principle that is used to show their
totality so as we said total problems
are the ones where a solution exists and
to in order to show that a solution
exists we use a mathematical principles
on for example to be pigeonhole
principle or parity which we will see
later
and the the problems are classified
according to which of this principle is
used so using this idea she defined all
of these classes and and many others
have class were introduced later these
subclasses have found many applications
in game theory economics optimization
and the most celebrated result is that
finally can ask you Librium is prepaid
the complete and also they have found
many applications in cryptography - so I
am a first question for the subclasses
is whether we can find natural complete
problems for them and in for this talk
naturally will mean that a problem does
not contain pure in machine or a circuit
as part of the input so let's see an
example of this definition so here is a
problem we are given that
caption of non-terminal security messing
animate Putin X and the output should be
the value of M of X okay so this problem
is by definition np-complete and another
problem that is np-complete through you
to cook 11 theorem is that it's at right
and then use except we can find we can
have many other np-complete problems so
in this case the first problem is no
naturally because it has a
non-deterministic Turing machine whereas
the second one is natural okay superior
the difference between natural I'll talk
about two results that have to do with
finding natural yeah it it is used in
this area not sure what it's not my
definition says that they shouldn't
contain an explicit description for
Turing machine in the input so yes but
we cannot really have a technical
definition right because sad can't
describe during machines yeah exactly
that's yeah
so then I'm going to talk about two
problems the two works the first one is
for identifying complete problems for
these two classes people pay and week
therapy and the connection that this has
two lattice based cryptography is that
our complete problem looks at looks like
a generalization of this is and because
of its its hardness for for this class
we can get something about collision
resistant hash functions and that'll
explain it a bit later the second one
has to do with this class PPA and again
it has a connection with us is because
we saw that for some range of parameters
we can reduce the size to a problem
that's called chevalier so let's start
with the first result and that has to do
with people P and week with P so as we
said these classes each one of them
describes our different mathematical
principle so base book classes have to
do with a pigeonhole principle let's see
the definition so people pin in P
beeping the input is a circuit and we
are looking either for a pre-image of 0
or a collision and the circuit has n
inputs and an output so we know that
either
it is compressing so there exists a
collision or it it's a permutation so we
can find our primitive 0 and that's why
these problems complete and the people P
contains all problems that are it useful
to this one in which P P the circuit
that we have as part of the input is
compressing so M is less than n and in
this case we are looking for a collision
these classes have very strong
connections with cryptography particular
weak PP contain soil collision resistant
hash functions in the sense that if we
can solve which will be is if we pivot
reason P then collision resistant cannot
exist and similarly we have a connection
between P P and one with permutations
so let's see and some connections that
they have with lattices I'll start by
showing the reduction to two people bit
off from makovski which will be the
problem that I defined to be with P and
this is an easy reduction but I'll just
show how this and this complex the
glasses work
so in makovski the assume that we have a
base of our lattice B and the output
should be a vector in the lattice with
infinity norm that it's less than that's
to 1 over N and this problem we can call
it also share my test with infinity but
I'll stick with the name makovski and we
show and also in another work it is
shown that the mikorskis P P is in P P
so let's see how this can be done first
what we have to do is to create a
circuit a PPP circuit and then make sure
that if the circuit return side there
are primitive zero or collision then we
can find out a solution to makovski so
I'll I'll show you
and so the how this works through an
example so assume that we have this to
the lattice that has determinant a so we
are looking for a vector that has
infinity normalized and sqrt AIDS so
it's in this square I will construct
this mapping that Maps points of this
rectangle in this reticle there are 9
points to the parallelepiped of of the
lattice that has eight points equal to
the determinant so how this this mapping
will work will just reduce these points
modulo the parallelepiped in literal why
this reduces makovski to the P first if
we find the collision then this means
that we have two points that map to the
same point in the in the parallelepiped
and this means that their difference
should be in the Lud's right in the
other case if we find the perimeter
zero then this means directly that these
point is in the lattice and the only
problem that that we haven't addressed
is that we have a trivial solution the
zero zero so what we have to do is just
a remove remove it from them the mapping
so now we have a point and the mapping
is from 8.4 8.0 we can have a circuit
like that the only problem is that these
points are not really described with 0 1
to the end as a 0 1 to the N vector and
that's there is a there are some steps
that are ok we can say that this path of
0 1 to the end we can be numbered from 1
to K and then we have to find a mapping
that map's this 1 to K 2 to this square
then use a mapping to the parallelepiped
and then use a different map here's a
different function to maps to map these
points to 1 up to K and this is the only
non-trivial part of the reduction for
this we use a Smith normal form of the
basis B but I want to tell you more
about that ok any questions about the
makovski
so let's see now why sis is in people
pee so I'll describe sis because it is
connected with our complete problem is a
is the first step to go to define our
complete problem so say yes has an input
a matrix a that is in Z Q and has arrows
and M columns and we have this extra
condition that M has been more than a
lot Q times R and the output should be a
vector that it's short in some sense
such that ax is equal to 0 mod Q and we
want to remove the trivial solution in
our case we will consider the hardest
version of SAS so we consider
infinity-norm to be less than or equal
to 1 and this problem is equivalent to
this formulation where we have we are
asking for two x and y's such that FX is
equal to a of y module let's see why why
this problem is taught on the first step
is to see how many how many elements are
in the domain so since we have a since
each one of them can take values 0 1 to
the M there are 2 to the M of them and
the output is the image size is key to
the R because the matrix a has R rows
and each one of them can take any of the
Q values right and then using this
condition we can now we can see that the
domain size is more than the image size
so there must be a collision this
problem is total and it is to see that
this problem is actually in we will be
by just describing the circuit as ax mod
Q so now we can now we can move on to
our result
but is that constraints is is week will
be complete so I'm I just described the
week will be P but we get a similar
result for P 2 P 2
yeah
how is it different from interesting
because if you take yeah and sorry
so if you take them large enough then
trying to find Victor if Norma doesn't
one
so is it isn't a special case of yeah
yeah WPP right which we don't get from
Macalester yeah and also it's like a
first step to for defining the other
problem
so let's see how how the constraint says
it looks like so we have the matrix a
that we have in desire so but also we
have an X extra matrix T that has a
special form that we call it binary in
vegetable and then the outputs would be
again an exit Y and such that a of X is
equal to a of Y module so this is the
same as I say yes but additionally we
have we need this extra condition then
the G of X and G of Y are both equal to
0 and notice that these two conditions
are different so in the second case we
want that G of X is equal to 0 mod Q and
the G of Y is equal to 0 mod Q so not
only that they collide so let's see
first why this problem is total before
so in that it's week will be complete
and we have to define what the binary
facebook matrix is so binary invertible
matrix looks like that
it has this form is an upper triangular
matrix and in the diagonal it has this
vector seeds the tire powers of 2 like 1
2 4 up to fume and unexampled I serve
this matrix so as we can see this is a
below the diagonal
Teredo then the day are going to have 1
2 4 1 4 and then up above the diagonal
you can have any any number mod Q so a
very important quantity for this matrix
is this the the number of columns that
are after the D vectors and this is
equal to n minus the low Q and let's see
why this is important because we can
prove this lemma so this lemma I am tell
is about finding solutions in the linear
system of GX equals to B mod Q so it
says that if we pick any B and n easy
that fix any binary see that fixed this
last this last element of X then we can
always expand it to to a binary solution
of this system
and let's see the proof through an
example so assume that we have the
previous matrix T and in this case these
just one bit so it's the last bit we can
fix it to say 1 and then B 2 anything
let's see how we can extend this to a
binary solution of this of this system
first we start with the last over the
last row of T this has only three
nonzero elements so it it involves these
three variables and as we can see from
the definition of the binary vegetable
this has the powers of 2 so 1 2 4 so
this gives us an equation that the
solutions are the binary the composition
for number mod 8 basically so we can
figure we can fill this with a binary
with binary values and then we can go to
the next one again we have the 1 2 4 so
again we can find a binary solution and
let's see how many solutions we can find
our system since we have all of these
variables that we can take and value 0 1
to the n minus the local the solutions
are at least that many so the domain of
the of this problem the domain size is 2
to the M minus de la Q and their aim at
size is again like e to the R with a
similar argument to sis
yep the problem is just consisting of x
and y that already solved yes
so I'm I'm picking this money and then
I'm extending it using the lemma and so
because this is efficiently domain I can
fission we find elements in this domain
that's kosher yeah
so they matzah sq2 they are and then
using the new condition that we have
here where the D appears that these the
number of roles in G and it appears here
the problem is Toto and actually the
problem since the only argument that we
use to show that is a pigeonhole
argument it's a whole principal argument
then this problem C is in wit could be
two so now let's see why it is hard so -
so hardness we have two so that we can
buy that by you by solving this problem
we can find cohesion in any in any
compressing function so this compressing
function we can describe it with as a
circuit that has n inputs and n minus 1
output and this circuit and we will call
the input X and the output Y and we
assume that this circuit contains only
none gates ok without loss of generality
then we will use a matrix T of our
concern is is to describe the evaluation
of the circuit so and they will make
sure that what we have here what that it
contains the input X and the output Y is
actually an evaluation of this circuit
the circuit C and then we will use the
matrix a just to make sure that we have
a collision for T so that meaning that
the Y's are equal into into two inputs
so let's see how we can describe the
evaluation of a circuit through matrix T
oh yeah and because it's easier I'll I
won't prove the result for 0 I'll just
prove it for 2 and then we can there are
there are some other technical steps
that we can remove the tool so as we
said that the the take it contains only
NAND gate so assume that we have a NAND
gate with the inputs x1 and x2 and
output Y see how we can describe it
through a modular linear equation so
this we have this equation that has x1
and x2 that are the input Y and then
our variable and as we can see from from
this table the only zero one the only
the only binary solutions of this
equation are the one that corresponds to
Y being the amount of X 1 and X 2 and we
believe the actual so using this we can
describe we can define one role of the
matrix T and then we can do the same
thing for it for its gate of the circuit
so we can have a whole matrix thing and
what it's like to show is the prismatic
seed is actually binary invertible so it
has this form of upper triangular we'd
want to want to on the diagonal because
we are just not for here and from the
previous equation we can see that it has
this one two and also by by observing
that the second is actually a dull and
we can use we can use this this special
structure of a circuit to put the the
inputs on the bottom and the outputs of
the upper upper side of t to make sure
that g is invertible it's binary
effectively then now we can have the
evaluation of the circuit described by a
circuit by the matrix T and we have to
make sure that we have a collision using
game so it just says that so you say
just to make sure that y 1 should be
equal to Y 2 so I can just be identity
in the part that we have Y 1 and 0
everywhere everywhere else now the only
thing that it's left to show is that we
have this this condition now I'm not
going to describe it but this condition
is guaranteed so this problem is is an
SI constraints is instance and if we can
find our collision to this problem then
we can
the collision 22 the second say so this
is with a baby pig completely like
what's the benefit of describing the
problem with the more general matrix
seems like you showed that an even
easier problem yeah the benefit is to
show that everything else easing is in
weakly with me actually the benefit is
to saw the connection that has the
collision resistance as function because
with every for every problem that is in
quickly with me we can describe a
collision resistant and it is in this
case using car problem the concern
science wouldn't describe this collision
resistant this has functioned that we
can conjecture the collision resistant
the input of a key is the matrix a which
now is random and we know that all of
these instances are in quick therapy and
binary invertible matrix t that we can
sample by sampling the elements of over
the diagonal basically and then to
evaluate the collision resistant we can
have an input of size local VI and then
use the lemma to extend X to a solution
of DX equals to 0 mod Q and then thus
output a times X DX mu Q so this is a
this is a hospital that looks a lot like
the SAS house function but it also has a
worst-case guarantee that says that if
this hash function is easy then no no
collision resistant hash function can
exist yes its worst case yes yeah but by
their examples to si yes it also has all
the average case all the everything that
we know for SAS also holds for this
collision resistant you think it's as
hard as yeah yes because if we can find
the solution to this one then this is a
solution this is to
slightly different parameters or
something like yeah em has to be more
than something that depends on the on
the dimension of tea
okay so I'll move on to the next result
which is about this class the PPA which
contains all party arguments and we
again saw some completeness some
completely result for a generalization
of this classes that are for modulo P
arguments but I'm not going to explain
the result at all I'll just so the the
connection that it has with some
versions of sis so let's see what is a
parity argument so I'm the PI T argument
states that if we have an odd number of
vertices and the matching on them then
there must be an isolated node and we
can generalize this to modulo oh yeah
and it has many connections to topology
because Barcia Coulomb is a pape a
complete and fair division and
computational geometry when we can
generalize this to a modulo P argument
in this case we the principles of
following assumes that we have a graph
with non multiple of P number of
vertices and we have an P dimensional
matching so assume that the this in this
case we have P equals 3 and then we have
the this hyper edges then this argument
says that there must be at least one
isolated node and we have shown some
similar results to the one with as we
have for PPA in particular we saw that a
version that it's a it's a
generalization of the borscht Coulomb
theorem is PPP complete and also that
some results with some problems in per
division are in PPP and it's a very
interesting urban problem whether they
are actually PPP complete so now the
problem of the the landscape of EFMP
looks like that we have PPA and blue
that are distinct for from P P P and P
pay these on in all of these classes
okay so I'm the problem autocomplete
problem and the connection with the
science has to do with a problem that's
called a ballet in this problem we have
modular system for normal system f1
through a fan that have each one of them
has m variables and we want to find a
solution into the system modulo P so the
serval a warning theorem says that if
for the sum of degrees of these
polynomials is less than the number of
variables then the number of old
solutions is 0 mod p in the special case
this is called this valley warnin
condition the special case for this of
this theorem is when the constant terms
of the polynomials are 0 in this case we
know that the old zero solution is a
trivial solution to the system
polynomials so the civil a theorem says
that there must be at least one nonzero
solution and this is what we define as
the computational version of several a
let's see what is the connection with
the sis so I'll show a reduction from
actually a stronger a stronger problem
than SAS that asks for binary solutions
to a system ax equals to 0 mode therapy
so this also gives us a reduction from
SAS but in the case that the parameters
satisfy this condition so we have n
times P minus 1 is less than m and the
blur but this is not the usual range of
parameters for SAS so we want m to be
linear in P
obviously these pizzas on the site
solution so let's see how we can use
several a to solve this problem we
define this the polynomials one for each
row of a as follows these are the
elements of the death row and then we
have just X X I to the P minus 1 and
from Fermat's little theorem every
solution to this to this system
polynomials will be a zero one solution
so now we just have to count the the
degree of effect so each one of them has
the creep in minus 1 and we have n
polynomials because the number of rows
of a are n so from this condition we
have that n that is the number of
variables is more than n times P minus 1
and hence from chevalier this has to
have at least one nonzero solution
so I'll conclude with a few open
problems related to this complexity
classes and the cryptography and
lattices so these are the things that we
know now so from people people we know
that constraint is these two things are
equivalent constraints is this BP
complete and also we know that means
oxygen all the problems that are implied
by that tie reduce Ponte makovski are in
PPP so in this direction for lattice is
an interesting problem is what happens
with the square root n is BP so this is
the the factor of s BP that we know that
it lies inside and pìkô MP so we don't
know anything about so it's interesting
to see if it actually lies in one of
these classes and not just any Co MP and
also not for other classes not people P
it's interesting to see if for example
this IPP or any other lattice problem
lies in one of the other classes we
don't know anything about that
also there are many cryptographic open
problems in these directions for example
this is what we know now so we know some
assumptions in pls in PPP everything
that gives us a collision resistant
owned or one whipp'd mutations and then
we have some special assumptions that
they are inside CLS like IO or repeated
squaring so it's a very interesting to
see if for example factoring Gordon log
Aranea there essentially is in these
classes especially the PPA D class this
this consider a very very interesting
comment problem and yeah this these
questions are about inclusion two
classes so let's see some open questions
about hardness of these classes so it
would be very interesting to show that
minkowski's will be hard which has been
conjectured many times and some other
hardness the result will be interesting
is to show whether for example square
root n CBP which is like a hard large
problem is harder than
one of these classes may be CLS or any
other CLS is considered the easiest all
that so that's why I put it there and
this would give us some implication to
Krypto - because here less as I said
contains some cryptographic assumptions
of course in this direction so the most
interesting would be to have some
hardness for inside SIV P because this
would directly gives us some hardness
for average-case say yes and the most
interesting class - so this would be the
weak PvP that contains all collision
resistant because in this case we could
so that sis is like in very solid police
resistant hash function so let me
conclude with our again with the open
result so the open problems are in the
intersection of T and P and the lattice
theory or in the FMP and other
cryptographic assumptions and also
another direction that I haven't
mentioned but is again very interesting
is whether we can believe cryptography
whether we can find new cryptographic
primitives using TIF and B and using the
structure of different problems
we have time for questions so this the
class keep you feel like clothes under
like if you can turn reduce no baby
please the only one that it's not that
BPA ease and the baby okay because I
because I was gonna say about like
factor n SVP and you call me cask
but that doesn't help me what sense it
doesn't care i think i turning
reductions don't work but the oh I think
you're talking about this right I mean
it's not yes it's under cheering
reductions yes that's Rob so it's not
formally in PPP but the let's assume
that is fine yeah so the interesting
direction is the opposite shows
something card like reduce people Pete
do something to a Lots problem
you showed like a square so like the
ohnfiddle but it still holds my guilty
normally yeah I've been finding armies
the heart is right and we are looking
for inclusion so
so what do you think well it may be
possible to get from TMT so first of all
you bet there are interesting problems
in the other direction too so using
cryptography to show over its case
hardness of these classes in particular
this is part this is very interesting
for pped because it was so average case
for NOS but you're asking whether we can
have a worse stability case it doesn't
for one of these problems right there
any problem this is believed to be hard
on average in this classes is there any
candidate there are two different
definitions of hard on average right
there's there's no polynomial time
algorithm and we think there's a
reduction from some class to the average
case problem a reduction from all
collision-resistant hash functions even
in the worst case to an average case yes
yes great which is like a lot stronger
than just saying that the problem is
hard on average isn't as hard as the
whole class I mean this is yes this this
is what we would get even from something
like that right this if we had this then
this would say that sis is at least on
average is at least as hard as the whole
class CLS and all the problems at CLS
contains you be able to say if you're
okay any more questions let's take
Caterina
[Applause]